what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today
we have conversations with a feminist
i'm a conservative and i'm a feminist
and today we are reacting to ben shapiro
smacks down black lives
matter how does what do you think so far
based on the title
i don't know i have no idea what
anyone's going to say but i will say
black lives matter organization is a
scam but
i don't disagree with the the saying
that was actually my first question was
i wasn't sure
it seems like everyone was really for it
at the time but now it's like kind of
coming out that there's no one no one is
for the actual organization really no
because they're [ __ ] scammers no i
mean like like back when i was in high
school it was like really
like you could not say anything bad even
about the organization
no i think just the whole time like the
the point is to
like emphasize that black lives matter
and to make that evident in life versus
the organization like
okay
so this is basically ben shapiro he
is debating these are like
representative representatives for black
lives matter
okay this was very viral back in the day
things i wanted to share with you
according to pew research the net worth
of white families in 2013 was 141 000.
for black families it was eleven
thousand even less than the nineteen
thousand it was in two thousand seven
according to economist edward wolf of
the university of new york excluding
vehicles and other durables the median
black family worth is just seventeen
hundred dollars
while forty percent of black families
have zero or negative wealth
white family worth
in terms of uh financial worth is 69
times more than that of black families
given this disparity
how can you argue that racism is not a
driving factor in income inequality
because it has nothing to do with race
and everything to do with culture and
when you have a culture that doesn't
and when
and when
you know what explain to me you explain
to me why black kids aren't graduating
high school explain that one to me
explain to me why black kids are
shooting each other in rates
significantly higher than whites are
shooting each other explaining why 13
percent of the population is responsible
for 50 percent of the murder explain to
me why the why the number of blacks and
black kids in prison not for innocent
reasons not for walking down the street
and getting pulled into a prison is so
high explain if it has nothing to do
with culture explain to me why the
single motherhood rate in the black
community jumped from 20 to 70 percent
in the same course of time that the
civil rights movement has made such
tremendous strides is america more
racist now than it was in 1960 and if it
is please explain to me how that
happened
so what do i think those riots are i
think oh well
what do you think of that
i think it's always been nice it's like
he's like oh like
it's been racist it started with racism
the [ __ ] foundation
um
so i don't
i don't know i don't pretend like i have
the answers you know
but when he asks the question like if if
it's about racism why were the stats
worse in the 70s than they were before
like i don't know how to answer that
question
i think we look for different things so
as time goes forward especially um
comparing like
oh
if racism was then in racism now it's
like it can present itself in different
ways and also um
i hope that no one can deny that america
was founded on racism being that
um
they
from the beginning of like the
colonization of america slaves were
people africans were enslaved and
brought over here um
to
literally build america and do different
works
so
obviously
racism then like starting out and
after slavery
there were different
um
different things enacted to
like because slavery was legal then but
they enacted different things that were
legal so that they could still have
different forms of whatever they were
wanting to do and even how he brought
about uh
the 70s we talked about last time how
they were
you said the government was paying for
mothers to be single so
well yeah and that but that's his point
his point is like
that the single motherhood rate is so
high in the black community not because
of like racism but because like of the
government making a policy
that to like pay to take the mother the
dad out of the home but why would they
want the dad out of the home um
i don't know i think i think they wanted
sometimes i think like people in the
name of like how do i put it in the name
of empathy make really shitty laws so i
think the idea was the law was supposed
to help single mothers
yeah like because that's what the point
was like you get this amount of money if
you're a single mother
but then like it's almost
i'm saying i'm not i actually have a
theory that
maybe there's something going on behind
the scenes
but
i don't know i i just i literally can't
answer the question when they say
like why weren't the stats worse like
because you would think in the 30s and
40s it was closer to slavery so the
stats would be worse than like people
would be i don't think so
uh
i think people are the same
like
as racist as they were back then it's
just different ways like they're
discreet about it
it's very discreet
what's like discreet racism
that is
say it is is really subtle things okay
and it
mostly like most of the time it will be
really sly okay and i won't say most of
the time but in certain settings it'll
be um sly
and
even gaslighting in a sense because say
oh pro i was treated this way no no you
weren't treated that way like i was
there with you but it's something that
you wouldn't notice because it was done
discreetly
um
but how would you know it's like racism
versus someone just not liking you
well you can
you can look at them you feel like you
can tell the difference yeah because say
say if you're in a room with certain
people and if you're the only one that
looks a certain way or like you can be
doing the same exact thing or acting the
same way or not even
presenting your full character to other
people um and then it's like why are you
treating me differently or why are you
treating that person differently if
everyone is in here or
they didn't do anything to you they
didn't say anything to you
um
so you feel like if do you feel like if
if there was like more than one black
person and like they were mean to you
but nice to them then you wouldn't think
it was racism
yeah but it just it depends on the
situation because it's not
black and white in that sense but also
is this when you know you know
do you ever think that like do you have
you ever been in a situation where you
thought someone was racist at first and
then you were wrong
or were you always like right
immediately
i mean i don't necessarily go around
saying like oh you're racist yeah um i
just go based off of the experience so
okay um
there are certain things that will be
done like racist things okay in that
sense um and then i'd say that from
there but i don't just go around saying
oh xyz is racist no i'm not i'm not
saying you are it's just like earlier
when you said you can tell the
difference yeah you don't exactly
you can tell um because i i don't
i don't think anyone
wants to be like oh that person is
racist or like willingly wants to be
around racist or yeah
really wants to be around racist in the
sense of oh yeah everyone's going to be
racist i'm going to be there it's just
something that you pick up along the way
yeah
well so what do you think about
like things like jesse symbolic
like how
well he was lying right yeah he got
charged no no but so when i say there's
something big that happens in society
right it's indicative of the whole
society because on smaller levels things
like that have probably happened
so just i'm wondering how do you know
the difference between somebody like
making something up and someone telling
the truth do you feel like you should
automatically believe people when they
say stuff like that
i think
you do due process okay
and figure out from there
um
because none of us have to answer in the
beginning that's quite literally why we
use due process yeah
okay
um no because i don't i don't have the
answers it's just like sometimes
i'm like
if there's no if they didn't do anything
specifically racist
like i wouldn't call someone racist but
it sounds like you're saying maybe
like if someone treats you a certain way
you might think they're racist
even if they didn't say anything yeah i
can differentiate someone not liking me
or versus someone being
racist or biased in essence if you would
like to use the word bias okay
the depravity i think they're thugs and
i think if you really want to make a
difference
thurgood marshall who grew up just two
blocks from there did such a thing who
was a contemporary of martin luther king
now i'd like to skip over to dr seacrest
who is she calling thugs
what was this was um
let's see what year this was this was
2017. so i want to say that was ferguson
maybe
this was this was when like black lives
matter was really
like let me see
if we google it 2017
please shooting
it's not gonna be just one thing coming
up no no
oh that was in minneapolis do you
remember that
no because it's too many to remember
okay um
yeah this was people were rioting in
minneapolis i want to say
but that's like basically the context is
there was just um
a police shooting
i i look at the baltimore uprisings as
more than just riots right i hate the
idea when you say thugs and riots right
white people riot as well when y'all win
super bowls two years in a row y'all get
off the hook don't make it seem like
it's just baltimore getting upset
so my 32nd answer is i feel the
frustration
of what's happening in the community and
i think it's a symptom the the uprisings
are a symptom
of
a pressure that's been unaddressed for
too long
i'm offended by the language of uprising
applied to people who are breaking into
other black people's stores and looting
them uh this is not this is a lack of
values and people who people who are
destroying private property destroying
cop cars in an uprising against what
exactly against the black police chief
against a mostly minority police force
against the black mayor against the
black president against the black
attorney general against the entirely
against a city council that is nine of
15 are black and all 15 are elected
democrats what is the uprising against
what is it seeking to achieve i still
don't see what exactly the the riots are
seeking to achieve bottom line is
this is all
it all could be boiled down to just act
like a mensch
act like a human being honestly it's not
a useful it's not useful to riot it's
not useful to break things it's not
useful to throw rocks at people and the
idea that we're supposed to sort of
correlate your level of outreach i'm
gonna stick to the 30 seconds yeah the
last time the lessons the idea that
we're supposed to correlate your level
of outrage with a certain level of
justification in other words the more
outraged you are and the more angry you
are the more justified you must be is
absolute nonsense
[Applause]
then since the issue of disparity has
come up numbered
i think that is
wrong saying that it's pointless to
um to rally okay because there's power
in numbers and also when
people are getting in these groups
rather as
um peaceful or non-peaceful um
when
these large gatherings are had
you're able to see at a larger tail like
oh what are what are they here for or
what are they doing
versus it's just you and i and we're
like oh no don't do this anymore no
one's listening to us because we're just
two people so i think that's senseless
to say no
they look at the history
and the course of the different laws
that have been passed in america because
people have been rallying
so
question do you think it's okay to riot
because he did specifically say riot
so i'm talking about looting in the
stores it works for friends
okay so that's that's how you you feel
like it's okay as long as it
i mean
if no one here's the thing
um
if no one is listening to you either way
not saying that it's right because it's
not me to say that it's right i mean i
wouldn't want someone destroying my
stuff um
but in this sense like most of the time
and i'm not justifying it but most of
the time these places have insurance for
one and two if you're not listening like
the point is to make a statement
so if you're not hearing anything until
i have to make the biggest statement
that i can make
do you feel like criminals take
advantage of this of like
of rat like riots
yeah i'll say that also um especially we
can go to um
[Music]
was that
was that minneapolis um oh i think i
thought this is no this is baltimore but
yeah yeah minneapolis whenever
i think 2028
yeah the riot in 2020 and minneapolis um
most of the people that were in there
are like it was started by white people
and um most people that were in target
stealing were black like their videos
of people going shopping and stuff
and using using the
using it as a time to actually still
versus just make a statement because
most of the time they just damage things
like most most people that are
protesting they're just damaging things
to get their point across
not
stealing things
but there were loads of people like it's
on video no i know what you're talking
about i remember but
it almost makes the like the people that
are really there protesting look bad
yeah but they weren't even with them
what they weren't with them well i know
but a lot of like
there's people that were with them that
like
there's people that are part of black
lives matter and like that whole
organization that do it there's people
that just take advantage of it like
there's both but for me like
i think it just makes the whole
organization or like the movement as a
whole look bad when you have people
rioting
and like a lot of times they're
destroying minority communities so it's
just interesting how they say black
lives matter but you're going to destroy
minority communities in the process like
it almost seems like that would be
counter-intuitive to the goal
like like um because a lot of the
businesses that are hurt are black-owned
businesses
like i i run a business right if someone
looted this i would be done like there
would be no coming back that's like
thousands of dollars worth of equipment
if someone looted me and like broke my
[ __ ] i would have nothing
and so i can like really empathize with
like business owners in that sense
because i don't think there's any coming
back especially like you know maybe i
could go to my parents but most people
especially like
in
you know lower income communities they
can't always do that
so it's just it makes me think it might
not be
like it makes me wonder what the
intentions are if like in order to
accomplish something you have to destroy
like black owned businesses to do it
like because like because while shouting
black lives matter like it just seems
weird
i don't think that's necessarily the
point and i it might not be the problem
no i'm not saying that but i also i
haven't seen so i would be interested to
see
um
the data around that that is actually
black businesses being um
affected
um
and i also think the difference is
obviously you know you are
having like you are
operating a business but the difference
between
you and
the other places their actual store
fronts and they have insurance
um
there's no i don't know any storefront
place that you can operate in without
insurance
um
do you think it matters if the owners of
the business are black or white
i don't i don't necessarily think it
matters but i do get your point of
saying that you're affecting the people
that you're
meaning to represent uh also
um
i think the biggest thing is just making
a statement
okay because again when when people do
things peacefully um
they're not being recognized they're
they're not recognized no one and aside
from
black lives matter or
like that movement anything out of that
people people are not taking seriously
unless they they go on the the violent
slide so to speak
so um
question do you
do you think that
it
like like what policies do you feel like
would are they fighting for
because
like what what specific policies because
in my in my eyes there's always going to
be bad cops
so you can't really eliminate that
problem and just say bad cops stop being
police officers like there's always
going to be shitty people in every
industry
yeah granted in every area of life
they're always going to be good and bad
i think the difference says um
letting it be a a
slap on the wrist
because
no one should be taking anyone's life um
yeah i don't think anyone should be
taking anyone's life for one and two
um
if if some of these like officers are as
afraid as they they are claiming to be
maybe you shouldn't be doing that job
like i'm not going to be a a pro boxer
because i don't want to be punched
so if you're doing a a dangerous job
and you're you feel like you're going to
be scared all the time maybe choose a
different profession because
obviously they're every cop isn't bad
but a lot of them are bad
um and you just have to acknowledge that
like no one can say that there aren't
any bad cops
um
but i think the main thing is
um
not being able not being able to
take advantage of the privileges that
they have um because just because you're
a police officer doesn't mean that i
have to do everything under the sun that
you're saying
um because we're all under the same
government the same laws right
governments we are binding under um
and just because you feel entitled
does not make you actually entitled like
that's just your feeling um
but if these people are being
reprimanded
then i think that would make a
difference because why am i going to
kill you and then it's like oh i get to
have a paid vacation
why am i having a paid vacation if i
just killed someone
so um
question do you think
are you do you know michael brown
in new york
um i believe we can google it he was in
i thought he was in ohio like
brown ferguson that's where
location
i don't know i know ferguson i think
that's in ohio oh missouri i knew it was
saint louis
yeah
okay do you do you remember this case
no
so i i believe and you guys can correct
me in the comments if i'm wrong i
believe this was like the first one
this was like where black lives matter
started uh michael brown uh no it was
before that which which one was it i
think it would have been closer to
trayvon martin
uh so this is 2014. let's look at
trayvon martin
date
it's 2012. oh okay
trayvon martin i was in orlando florida
okay i the michael brown i wasn't eric
gardner i don't remember um
i think michael brown but i'm just gonna
use this case because i don't um
i don't know enough about trayvon martin
to really talk about it but in the in
the case of
michael brown do you think
wait can you bring up what that case is
again because i know the name but
michael brown okay
so
the shooting of michael brown so
michael brown was unarmed
okay and that and so like the media was
talking about how an unarmed black man
was like shot by a white cop or by
police right yeah and but it turned out
that he was trying to take the cops gun
and this was a really big like a really
big case
in the us
and like it was all over i think i was
in 2014 i think i was in eighth grade i
remember this
high school i don't know i'm sorry my
memory do you feel like
in that case they have a right to shoot
him because he's trying to take the cops
gun
i think at that point is self-defense
but i i don't even know like
i i'm not saying anything about other
than
um black man shot by why officer doesn't
say what's happening in that situation
um but
um
i i s where are you going the guardian
or just
no it was my the shooting of michael
brown
i'm not sure if it was michael brown but
i think it was
reporting the shooting of michael brown
okay brown that he responded to brown
reaching into the suv and punching him
by withdrawing his gun because he could
not access less lethal weapons while
seated inside of that suv
brown then grab okay okay wilson told
prosecutors and there's a hundred
eyewitness to like eyewitness um people
i witnessed testimonies that said that
um
that's that that cr oh my gosh that
confirmed this so wilson told
prosecutors and investigators that he
responded to brown reaching into the suv
and punching him by withdrawing his gun
because he could not access any less
lethal weapons while seating inside of
the suv brown then grabbed the weapon
and struggled with wilson to gain
control of it wilson fired striking
brown in the hand autopsy results
results in bullet trajectory skin from
brown's palm on the outside of the suv
door as well as brown's dna on the
inside of the driver's door corroborate
wilson's account during that struggle
brown used his right hand to grab an
attempt to control wilson's gun
according to three autopsies brown
sustained a close-range gunshot wound to
the flesh portion of his right hand at
the base of his right thumb
shot shoot suit from the muzzle of the
gun found embedded into the tissue wound
compiled with the in
indica of thermal charge from the heat
of the muzzle indicate that brown's hand
was within inches of the muzzle when
wilson's gun fired the coach the okay
blah blah blah blah blah
um
so the location recovered of the side
panels and the driver's side door just
above wilson's lap also corroborates
wilson's account of the struggle over
the gun when the gun was fired as do
witnesses accounts that wilson fired at
least one shot from inside the suv
so
and then
with the exception of darren wilson and
michael brown the names of individuals
have been redacted a safeguard against
the invasion of their personal privacy
although no eyewitness directly
corroborate wilson's account of brown's
attempt to gain control of the gun there
is no credible evidence to disprove
wilson's account of what occurred inside
the suv some witnesses claim that
brown's arm was never inside the suv
however as discussed later in this
report those witnesses could not be
relied upon in a prosecution because
credible witnesses account and physical
and forensic evidence dna inside the suv
and wilson's shirt collar and the bullet
trajectory and the close range gunshot
wound established that brown's arm was
inside the suv
okay so
basically but then it's funny because
you go here
if you google michael brown like it
doesn't
the media doesn't paint it like that
shooting of michael j brown like they
make it seem like when you hear shooting
like it seems like he was innocent in
the situation or just implies that he
was shot like i don't think it
to me that doesn't say
if someone's right or wrong it just
means quite literally you were shot
yeah i
when i when i hear like police shooting
that's what i think of someone innocent
was shot
but we could maybe just i think i think
you can say that based off of
the over the past few years of how the
media works but quite literally it's
just meaning that the police shot xyz
okay because they use that rhetoric all
the time it doesn't mean that but
my point is there was protests and this
was a huge thing yeah and so i think
that was dishonest
but by black lives matter and by that
whole movement because he was trying to
grab the gun
and like and you even agree like we
agreed that was self-defense
so it's just
like
that that's why it kind of makes you
look twice at situations like this
and like it makes me wonder like why is
the media so
like even in this case like people were
right like it was such a big deal when
this cop wasn't indicted but what about
the other cases the other cases
like not mike brown but all the other
cases well it depends on the case like
some i agree with some i don't
so like like for example i use so i
worked um
i think it's harder than you think to
differentiate a gun
from some like because i i did this
thing where i was in like a police
like i did like a virtual reality you
know and you have to be the police
and it like changed my perspective on
this stuff a lot because it's really
hard to tell for a second but my point
is like i just think it's harder than
you think for police to like
differentiate if someone's armed or not
so some cases i i think the cop should
be indicted some i didn't i think it
just depends on the case
but
like cases like this make me question
the whole movement as a whole
because
i'm like why why were they so dishonest
about that
and i think you're a little bit younger
than me but i like this was the reason i
remember this is because it was so big
like it was no i remember just being big
but it's not like a one-and-done thing
that's that's the thing is it's not
anything of the the biggest one for me
was
here are my biggest ones it would be
trayvon martin and then followed by
jordan davis because jordan he was
killed while i live in
jacksonville um remember him he was it
wasn't a police he was killed by this
guy he was like the music is too loud
oh that's [ __ ] up wow that's that's
crazy but he got away with that as well
um so cheryl martin jordan davis and
then alton sterling
um
was that the guy who killed trayvon
martin indicted no
he's innocent
george zimmerman i want to see the
is there a doj report
um
i do think the one problem i do see is
caught and cops is like power hungry
people
i wish i could can i get the actual
report
try that it says pdf
this one no below it no
okay
oh my god why would they do this to me
i hate it when stuff is printed out like
that
um
um
wait so you don't know about this case
i i i don't want to say anything that's
wrong i think i agreed with this one
like that like he should have gone to
jail
because wasn't it like a he wasn't even
a cop right no but he was just following
him
and what what happened
basically he was in his house and was
like oh there's someone in my
neighborhood that looks suspicious they
lived in the same neighborhood it's like
the neighborhood watch right and they
were like this the dispatch was saying
stay inside your house and we'll come
and investigate
and he's like no i'm gonna go outside
okay and so he goes outside and starts
following him and then he shot and
killed him
okay
well so then why why was he let go
was it i don't know it was [ __ ]
either way because
well the reason i asked why is because
when i was in the police training thing
if there and he's not a police officer
so i don't know how this works but it's
very hard to tell if someone's reaching
into their pocket and you only get a
split second so they're like if someone
if they say hands up and someone puts
their hand down like they have a right
to shoot because that's self-defense
well no he didn't have a right to shoot
him because no one told him like they
literally just said which is why why i
think i agreed with this one but i just
asked for all the facts like in a case
that's the only reason i just want to
know like why there had to have been a
reason like why he was indicted i mean i
was i would have been 11. so i don't
necessarily remember but either way is
[ __ ] because
if you were told to stay in your house
and if you're like if i'm scared right
and i'm inside of my house and i'm
scared why would i go outside of my
house and then follow the person that
i'm scared wait so we probably agree on
this i i'm just someone like i need to
know all the facts of a case before i
can like say one way or the other it's
like i don't know
but it's it sounds like i would agree
right
so
i don't know it's just
like some i agree with some i don't so i
don't really have a strong opinion
either way it's just
when
it seems like a waste when they're
they're like rioting and looting like
places
over someone that was like the first one
that i told you about michael brown but
i i don't think
obviously michael mike brown
mike brown case because that's what they
they don't refer to as michael brown
they refer to as mike brown okay um but
that was a big case because i do the
name rings a bell yeah um but there were
a lot of cases around that time at the
same time okay um
so
i get you're saying why you feel that
that could be dishonest for them to
pursue that case as a as a movement um
but there were multiple ones so i don't
i i don't want to say that this is
correct but i don't feel like it was
just because of mike brown that they
were like protesting okay um because
like
glendale still and like different ones
were like
they were a lot during that time okay
let's hear here
okay
when does disparity not indicate racism
level of effort statistical disparity
you know for example
overwhelmingly men commit crimes more
than women but we don't say that the
justice department is sexist so
is there is there a line that you draw
for yourself or is there some some way
that you interpret statistical disparity
and you determine that that is not a
racial disparity it's something else
well we can return to it that's okay too
ben do you want to yes
it's it's called evidence of racism when
there is no evidence of racism it's
probably not racism when there is actual
evidence of racism it's probably racism
and the fact that everybody jumps from
there's inequality and therefore there
is inequity just because there's
inequality does not mean there was
inequity but there has to be racism you
can't be considerate in the racism
no no no no no i'm just saying that i
don't know which animal or maybe
maybe we're talking about dogs or
something i'm talking about human beings
and i'm like
human beings are most likely going to
have racial prejudices i'm just so sorry
i i'm just so sorry i i don't know i i i
don't come in i don't come i come i come
from i come from planet earth charles i
just i want to ask you a question so
your default your default is that when
there is no evidence racism is the
deciding factor no no no it's not saying
that i'm just saying that uh that you're
gonna have sexist you're gonna have
racist you're gonna have all this stuff
i mean i'm just saying that i agree it
exists but the problem that i'm seeing
and this is the problem with the general
conversation is that there's no solution
in simply saying there's racism out
there how does that solve anything i
mean when you talk about there's
institutional racism what does that mean
show me a law that is racist in intent
and we will agree show me a police
officer who commits a racist act like we
saw in south carolina right where a
police officer shot a black man running
away and it was obviously unjustified
and i will agree
but you know
the the the idea that you can craft a
narrative based on no racism because it
just must be somewhere out there in the
ether that doesn't solve problems for
anybody and creates more problems for
people because now they grow up in a
milieu in an environment where they are
told that every obstacle they face is
from some shadowy nameless faceless
group who's out to get them simply
because of the color of their skin
they'll never succeed in that
environment
[Applause]
you know the weirdest thing is that
actually in the in the black home as i
experienced it really um there is no
discussion of racism
a racism actually is a discussion that
you actually come out and you face
in in the public because it's a real
thing that you have to actually expect i
mean if you you're silly and you're
foolish if you don't if you don't really
think that that's going to be there and
encountered in the real world i'm sorry
this is just a fact of life but if i'm
at home and having dinner uh with my
father or whatever we don't go oh my god
this society is so racist as i'm eating
my steak and you know what i mean
oh goodness gracious oh i can't bear it
my black skin is causing and we know we
don't we don't talk like that actually
we don't talk like that we talk about my
god um what's her name oh my god she's
got to take some pills because she's off
the register i mean i mean it's just
like this these are the conversations we
have at home
we don't have these kinds of
conversations that we're having right
now at least my childhood we didn't have
them and i'm watching
the people i knew growing up in the
black neighborhood i didn't hear anybody
really talking about race when we were
at the dinner table i mean it just
didn't really pop up unless he was in
issues on television but mostly it was
about family and and regular life but i
disagree i have to tell you even in my
culture there is an underlying racism
and i know that the panel today and
especially what's going on in america
we're talking about white on black but
you cannot i cannot wake up in the
morning and not think about you know
intercultural racism okay i'm not
mexican enough why because i'm
articulate and because i have straight
hair and i can wear high heels i don't
have a tattoo on my neck yes there is a
huge problem with racism no matter if
you're light-skinned or dark-skinned
absolutely there is inter-culture racism
it's absolutely underlying and why you
may not talk about it your grandmother
will have the favorite grandkid if she's
the lightest one with the good hair that
becomes the favorite grandkid in our
culture and that's you know
unfortunately even within our own
cultures we tend to look upon you know
the color of each other's skin and how
much education we have and if my uncle
has done time in jail which you know he
has then he becomes more mexican than i
am what is up with that i mean it's sad
but it's true it's absolutely true it's
like i can't eat spicy picante sauce so
i'm not mexican enough you know it's
true you know in every culture whether
it's asian you know black mexican there
is while you may not have grown up
talking about it over your you know uh
tea and toast i mean in my family if
you're not a doctor or a lawyer you're
not jewish not jewish enough
it's true
that part is true
this entire time i've been trying to
think about your initial question about
disparities are they automatically tied
to race and at first i think all of us
were stumped because we were trying to
think of the instances i
i do agree that they are separate that
they don't necessarily correlate within
itself there are disparities naacp we
are the experts inside of the nation of
bringing in the racial
lens for all of the work no they're not
necessarily going hand in hand or
they're not necessarily tied to each
other um
so that was that's how i would answer it
no they don't have to go together my job
as a civil rights attorney is to be able
to
make you see race at every given
opportunity but no it's not present in
each and every single disparity
two your second what are the standards
what are the standards of the difference
i mean you said that you want people to
see race in every single issue
where it's present okay so for instance
what's your standard as to where it's
present absolutely what's my um
for the take something as simple as a
if we're talking about a disparity say
men and women
my job would be to show what does that
look like when you have women from
a different
group communities of color what does it
look like when we're talking about a
woman who's working or stuck in a
minimum wage job not being not as a
starter but for her career right now i
guess the one question
so we bring in the racial dynamic of how
that affects i understand that the
question that i'm asking is when do you
decide something racist has occurred
racist yes when when do you have you
when can you decide that an act of
racism has occurred because if you have
just a statistical disparity hazard has
an act of racism automatically occurred
that was david's basic question i think
right there's a there's obviously a
there might be a
um
there will be a disparate impact on
different groups of people that doesn't
necessarily mean i think what you're
saying it doesn't necessarily mean
something racist is going on even though
there's a racial impact so the question
was about where do you draw the line
between something that might have a
racial impact but is not inherently
racist
yeah um let me move on in
so what'd you think of that part
because i think it was kind of asking
you the same question i asked you
earlier what was the question so he was
saying like when do you draw the line
between something that has a racial
impact and something that's racist
like when does disparity become racism
i i don't think i can like give like a
natural answer um only because i would
just have to think about that question
yeah it's a hard question um you can
come back next week
we'll have you back
but um
overall i i think
what the
the gentleman with the lawn care was
saying is that
no one no one is going at home and is
saying like oh yeah those people are so
racist
like you just talk about your
experiences in life
like
because that's true i don't i don't talk
to my
my family we don't talk like oh
oh
racism is this or racism is that we just
live our life and talk about our
experiences now we could have a shared
experience
and it's like that's what i'm saying you
have to look at things um and say like
well
i'm not i'm the only
person that looks like me here am i
treated this way because i'm the only
person that looks like me am i treated
this way because they don't like me
what are the factors
and so i think when you factor in those
things
you can get your answer like i am able
to get my answer so you feel like when
you talk to other people and they've had
the same experience that's kind of when
you decide it's like racism yeah because
it's like it would be a shared
experience because say i can be in an
environment um
i can be in an environment
um and i've been in different parts of
the world
i've been around different class yeah
and different economic groups and
whatever
the all the different groups that we
have right um and no matter where i'm at
like i can share an experience with
someone there and i think that's the
case in point that we cannot like i'm
sure you and i have some shared
experiences as women
we we don't know like because we haven't
we've only known each other saying for a
few weeks now but we've not we could
have uh
many shared experiences as women
and that's the point like i find that
women don't like my shared experiences
because i tend to think that life is
easier as a woman and all these women
need to stop complaining
so like what i when i think of shared
experiences it's usually like negative
and then when i come in i'm like no no
no no
like then what happens if like you have
an experience and i have an experience
like you say it's harder in the
workforce as a woman i say it's easier
i i would say our which is what i kind
of just go off individual people no but
i in that sense i and me assuming that
we would have a similar experience as a
woman i'm sure you've been
you may have been sexually assaulted you
may have been cat called you like there
are different things that just i feel
like every woman goes through no matter
what everything like that called yeah um
but i don't care like who cares it
doesn't matter if you care or not is the
the experience happening okay
that's like a shared experience yeah so
that would be a shared experience it
doesn't matter how you feel about it at
the end of the day okay it still
happened okay
did you get it no i understand right
yeah
so you're saying that like like all like
certain groups just have the same
experience yeah i think every every
group alike is gonna have somewhat of a
shared experience
um
and i think that's where it goes into
those stereotypes where um
the
the mexican lady was saying um she said
that she's mexican i mean the video yeah
yeah but she didn't she did um
where she's saying that she has
oh like oh you're not mexican because
you don't fit under these stereotypes
where you can be a better mexican
because you fit under these stereotypes
um and then saying you know i'm not
jewish enough because i'm not a doctor
or a lawyer
and i i think every group it doesn't
matter what your race gender sexuality
whatever like we're all to have shared
experiences and different stereotypes to
fit inside of those whatever category
i don't know
like because i think i know some women
that have never been like cat called i
just think it depends i think that's the
lie
i think that's the lie
that every
single woman has been catcalled
i do feel that way and i don't i think
it could be in the the sense of you
saying i don't i don't care like i don't
take offense yeah that's just your own
thing
and i'm gonna keep living my life so i
feel
if something can happen without having
an effect on you i think that's the
difference okay
but no i'm saying like like i'm sure
there's girls from like oklahoma
or like nebraska that that's just never
happened to because like to me
i've only been catcalled a couple times
in my life like in honor like all
honesty
it was like in in the city right so like
in in new york that's when i remember
being catcalled no it doesn't matter
where i'm at like
i guess you must just get it got it like
that
no but i don't i don't take it as
flattery like it's honestly it's not
flattering i just don't care like i just
like don't hear it it just goes over
like
like the couple times it's happened to
me i'm like okay i don't care like why
would i why would i get well a lot of a
lot of um
people will make sure that it's known
like even i was i
had gone back from out of town and i was
going to um get my mail and my neighbor
across the street this guy is like
[ __ ] 70 and he's like oh yeah
why are you are you talking to me yeah
like and it's not even like why are you
talking to me because i can talk to my
neighbors i can talk to anyone but
you don't have to sexualize me or
why are you saying this and the fact
that you're
what i nearly quadrupled my age it
nearly quadrupled my age and you think i
like i'm flattered by that like
no
yeah i just don't like because to me it
takes two seconds to just ignore it and
like keep yeah i'm not i'm not saying
that
your point is a lot of women have that
experience yeah robby you ignored or not
it still happened yeah okay okay yeah
fair enough um what was your thoughts
overall about this video do you hate it
i figured you'd hate it
i mean it's just it's just snippets and
obviously
these are the parts that have been like
because it's on his channel i didn't i
thought this was a full 10 minute i
actually did not realize i didn't watch
it i've seen this years ago but i didn't
remember like the full thing yeah but
it's like a three hour interview but i
thought it was just a ten minute you
know what i'm saying yeah but it was i i
think it was like about a biased side
again it's just it's ben's channel so
he's going to highlight the parts that
she does
i feel like i'm not on anything because
it was just like we heard like three
sound bites okay of the congregation
like there was no depth okay no fair
enough um
well thanks for coming on as usual i
like having these conversations i think
it helps understand each other's point
of view i don't have super strong
opinions either way i'm just more of
like
i need
to know all the facts in cases before i
make you know yeah i think obviously
like have all the facts but um just to
circle back um how
just aside from the mike brown case most
most of the cases that have been rallied
for
um
i don't feel that has been like even
tamir rice he had a a toy gun
like a little toy gun and he was killed
over that um flannel castile he had cds
well how was he supposed to know it
wasn't a real gun
like i'm sorry like how would he know if
it was a real gun
like i could see how a police officer
like i don't think like it wasn't a nerf
gun but do you think a nerf gun like do
you think a nerf gun looks real
um i think if it's dark yeah possibly
i'm telling you i if you did this
exercise you would die every single time
i swear to god because it's harder than
you think to differentiate and it takes
a split second for someone to grab a gun
and shoot you so would you say that
there needs to be more training then
um yeah there could be more training but
i also think it's on the other end of
the spectrum
you as the civilian it is your job to
learn keep your hands up and comply with
officers even if they're shitty officers
get the badge number and like deal with
it later but you have to comply
otherwise like you're putting both of
your lives like at risk
i see what you're saying so like like
keep your hand like if you keep your
hands up don't reach for anything like
i'm telling you i think that's fair to
say keep your hands up but at the end of
the day like people are going to do what
they want to do so if a cop has
intentions to kill me then that's their
intentions like i the last encounter
i've had with police he didn't say
anything to me it was a like a speeding
violation yeah he pulled me over well i
stopped because i knew he was coming for
me and
[Laughter]
i rolled my window down he was like
licensed my registration i handed to him
he didn't say oh do you know why i'm
stopping you or anything he just asked
for the stuff i gave it to him he left
he came back gave me and like walked
away but i don't i'm not to know what
his intentions were like i honestly was
scared when he stopped me because i
don't know like what you want to do um
and i think it's case the case like
obviously i think it can you can say
that that's fair to not automatically
assume for each person what their
intentions are
um
and to be as safe as you can but even if
i am doing what i'm supposed to be doing
it doesn't guarantee that you're going
to value my life any different
well it's no guarantee but it puts you
at a better odds
like because my mom even taught me like
she'd like always keep your hands at 10
and 2 for a traffic stop because a lot
of um
i don't know what the stat is but it's a
really large percentage of police that
gets shot it's at just regular traffic
stops someone that has a gun and isn't
like doesn't want to be pulled over
yeah and so like my mom taught me that
from a young age and like there's been
instances where i've seen where people
will complain about the police but i was
there and like there's a party that i'm
thinking about in college and the dude
was like oh the police did it up i was
like
sir i was there and you were being a
dick the whole night you weren't
listening to them you were arguing with
them the whole night
and like they had every right to arrest
you like you didn't get shot or anything
but like like i think there's
there's sometimes like it is your job to
comply with an officer
like because like you [ __ ] around you
might get killed
and i think that's like a conversation
we should be having like on our end too
this with like people like because i i
noticed that energy is more with young
people not really old people
the energy of what like like i don't
have to listen to you yeah like i've
just noticed like
i think generation doesn't seem to do
that i think it's a bit of both because
i've been around um older people that
like want to
argue um but like my mom especially her
biggest thing is just i'm gonna do like
the safest thing
and i can worry about filing a report or
doing whatever later on yeah um because
in the sense like i value my life more
but i don't i
i i do get that because again you never
know and if you do like just get it over
with and say like [ __ ] that's nice
but then also it's just like
i
i feel like it can be
that power struggle that you were like
kind of referencing like i have the
right to do this because you don't have
the right to just kill someone like just
because oh i feel this way or xyz i i
agree you don't but i think you have the
right to kill someone if you think your
life is in danger and if someone has a
toy gun and that you think it's a gun
like
that's really sad
but
like i
i don't think you should be indicted if
he genuinely thought it was a gun i mean
the kid was just playing in the park
like it wasn't like it wasn't like say
i'm right here and it's like oh bro
well i i heard that
i guess i'm remembering this case like a
long time ago didn't
i thought he was looking for like a
suspect
that had a gun that was on the loose and
he thought it was him
i could be wrong i don't like
i think we can both be not quoted in
this yeah
it's yeah like because i don't think
people are like like i think everyone's
on the same team like we want bad cops
to go to jail
but like my concern is just a lot of
people are making the cops out to be
like like bad guys when sometimes i
think they make mistakes
i i get that but i don't think taking
someone's life is a mistake like because
today if you're here that i can shoot
you in the knee and then now i've
disabled you mm-hmm
well they don't they shoot to move like
they they can't do that they have they
shoot at mass
like they're not trained like they're
not supposed to be trying to be like i
don't
remember like someone will have to like
quote this better but like you're
trained to shoot at the body of mass
like because if you shoot at the legs
like it could miss and go hit somebody
else
and so like so so
the more fleshy parts but it's like you
they're okay so first of all like with
that
there should just be more training like
i think we can both agree that there
should be more training yeah anyone
that's operating a gun needs to go
through thorough training um
because
again you can take someone's life using
a gun so rather you
like whatever your purpose of having
done you should go through training um
but especially like as a cop because
you're meant to
help society like you're meant to to be
there um for the community in that sense
um but i think
in that
you can have training to to safely
disable someone without having to take
their life and i do like there are
fleshy parts like you can shoot at
someone's abdomen and not kill them so i
think it's just a matter of that
training
i i
i think that that's like have you have
you operated a gun before yeah okay so
you know how to shoot yeah really wait
really
i don't i don't know many people that do
that are our age yeah like i don't have
a license but you know you can go to
like a gun ranger like it's it's hard
like i think that's that's tough yeah
but it
say if you're owning the gun because
even even though it's like state
property that's there that's your
personal gun yes this is pro police gun
yeah yeah yeah yeah like i didn't mean
to say like that but like i'm saying oh
i'm not getting a set but this is
this is your right that you're
responsible for this gun yeah so you
should have training and
know how to safely write i just realized
well my thing is i think there's a
reason they do it the way they do it
like i think body of mass makes the most
sense
like i don't think it makes sense to
shoot at their abs i think like the
whole point is like you need to stop the
target
yeah but that's what i'm saying there
are other ways to disable someone
without killing them
okay dude like so you're saying you'd
have it that they shoot at their abs
that's how you would do it
i there are lots of places you can be
shot that will not kill you okay but
you'd agreed have to be like the like
body of mass
i didn't agree that okay you don't agree
you think legs
i think this is if you're having the
training you'd have to do like research
because i
that's not my field of study like if you
want some pictures that's not i'm just
studying i just wasn't
okay okay like yeah that that was just
like they have to study and figure out
the logistics of okay so you definitely
do it yeah so what you'd like to see is
you'd like to see better training
maybe like to disable them instead of
kill them yeah definitely okay and then
also it's just i i feel like if you're
that scared as um
as a cop because
a cop's job a police a police officer
their job is to come protect and serve
the community
so if you're meant to protect and serve
the community all right guys sorry cut
off sorry we got cut off
i think it you said
oh you shouldn't be a cop if you're
scared basically
but my question is gonna be basically
like where is the line between making a
mistake and being scared because i don't
think it's like mostly them being scared
i think it's like just a mistake
sometimes
that's why you need to have training
like you know nurses or
people that have medical um license and
stuff they have to go through trainings
all the time it's not oh you're
certified in this good job for the rest
of your life however long you're having
this career but there's malpractice
insurance so like for doctors like
doctors make mistakes all the time it's
their time they're just insured
yeah but again like you are you're
having these trainings all the time it's
not a one and done thing okay so you'd
okay okay
um
well i think
is there anything else you want to put
in there no hopefully it doesn't sound
too bad because we don't know where we
left off that but no i
it's okay we might take it from we'll
see anyways
um okay well thanks again for coming on
i think these conversations are
important
um i think it's important to talk to
people that disagree with you and not
hate each other after i do hate you
well i did my best
okay guys um don't forget to like this
video um bring that notification bell
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
alright and i will talk to you guys next
time bye